- All right y'all, we are back
and we've got Seth Rogen and
Jessica Williams with us.
Give it up.
(applause)
So our next guest is
pretty much the definition
of an empowered woman.
She is an attorney, activist
and a number one New York
Times bestselling author
'cause she didn't have enough jobs.
Her latest project is a
children's book called
"A is for Ambitious."
Please welcome Meena Harris, everybody.
(applause)
- Did you--
- Hi!
- Did you know Seth or did
you know Jessica before?
- No. We've just met for
the first time today.
- Hi.
- I can't believe I'm the only,
apparently I learned,
the only one who's not a ceramist.
- No.
- I didn't get the memo.
- Oh, I've never, I've never done it.
- [Meena] Or ceramicist?
- Yeah! (laughs)
- I would want to, I would love to do it.
- [Meena] Right?
- But I've never, it seems
very hard, but I would-
- It's pretty hard.
- Yeah, it really is but once
you start getting those pulls
- And it's like therapeutic right?
- It is yeah.
- Very therapeutic.
- You like really you get to focus.
- Very, very. Yeah.
- I think I'll just focus still on songs.
(guests laugh)
So I was like, I think
that'll take me forever,
but I'd love to learn.
But congrats on the new book.
This is,
- Thank you so much.
- kind of a sequel of sorts, right?
- It is.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So the first book that came-
this is actually my fourth kid's book,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- which I never thought I would say.
It is the sequel to "Ambitious Girl,"
which is right there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And "Ambitious Girl" is really
about the word "ambitious"
and ambition and the way
in which we as a society
often use that word against
women and girls, and
- Yeah.
- It's about the power of language
and really reclaiming and
redefining these words
on our own terms. And-
- It's just so important
because ambitious,
and being ambitious,
is such a great thing.
But you're right, it can
be used so negatively.
- Exactly. It's a good thing.
I was raised to believe
that it was a good thing.
It's something to be proud of,
but as we all know,
society often tells women,
women of color, you know, hide that.
You can be ambitious but
not too ambitious, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Let's stay in your, stay in your lane.
So that's what the first book was about,
and while I was writing
it and then promoting it,
I was joking that I could probably come up
with a word for every letter
of the alphabet that
people use against women
- Yeah.
- and girls.
And I was like, wait,
that's actually a good idea.
I'm gonna write an ABC book.
So that's what "A is for Ambitious"
- is all about.
- So cool.
- Well I have an eight
year old little girl
and I love that you wrote this 'cause
this is very important.
- [Meena] It really is.
- To get to instill this kind of stuff
'cause they-
Words matter. They're so powerful.
- And doing it early.
Early on, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- In our homes, using the power of
- children's literature
- [Kelly] Yes!
- to embolden them and empower them
at a young age is so important.
Because you're right.
Like I grew up in the south
and that's where it's like, I mean,
be bold, but not that bold.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Meena] Right.
Like, don't outshine the boys.
Like, you know,
- Exactly.
that kind of thing.
No offense, I love boys, but-
- Ouch. Please, outshine away!
(guests laughing)
- So, Meena, you were
raised to be empowered.
Like you were raised
around pretty powerful women in general.
- I was, I grew up-
- [Kelly] I did some research
on you and your family.
- Oh!
- Yeah!
- Well, I-I did grow up in a
small family that was unique in that
it was all women.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
It was me, my mother, my
grandmother, who was really
a second mother to me and my aunt.
And I joke that it was
like the opening scene
of the Wonder Woman movie,
- [Kelly] (laughs)
like these incredible women of color,
just like running around,
saving the world, and-
- [Kelly] With incredible
jobs, like- yeah.
Really making-
- And all, you know, in service
and doing really, you
know, had purpose, right?
- Yeah.
- And now as a parent, I appreciate
that even more as an adult,
I appreciate that more,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- just how formative that was for me.
And I think about, you know,
how I'm raising my own children.
Not only how I can carry
that legacy forward
but also that my kids in-in
many good ways are growing
up in a different, you know, environment.
We let a few men in along the way,
[Kelly] (laughs)
so there's that, but you know
- To, you know, have the kids.
(laughing)
- Yeah, exactly.
- That, that, that's how that works.
And you know, just thinking
about parenting in my own way, right?
But so honoring what
was so formative for me
but really carrying that forward.
And it's ultimately,
in terms of the books,
the message is really that, you know,
we can do all the like girl power, rah rah
girl power stuff at home
but we know that when girls step out
into the world, it's-it's different.
- Is there a word or a
characteristic that you kind of
proudly represent that's
been, like, here's my thing:
I always wanted to be a
diva whenever I was a kid.
- Oh.
- I mean, that was Aretha Franklin,
- [Women] Yes!
that was Whitney, that was
Mariah, that was Celine.
It was all these amazing
women that I loved.
And then when I- by the
time I got to the industry,
it was like, that was a horrible,
shameful word to be called.
- Oh we should have put diva for "D"!
- No, I just-
- There's so many words, right?
- No, I know, there's so many words.
- Got another book?
- but it really-
(laughing)
- it-it broke-
(laughing) it broke-
- It broke my heart, though,
'cause I was like, oh man.
I was like, that was
like my goal as a child.
I was like, I'm gonna be
a diva when I'm older.
- [Meena] Right.
- You know, 'cause it-it,
you know, started with like,
you know, even classical
singers that were,
you know, these big operatic,
- Sure.
like, first sopranos that were just like,
oh my god, you know, a diva.
Like, and it cha- we've altered that name
- [Meena] Exactly.
- and, and it kind of sucks for me.
That's a word I love.
- And you know, it's like, it's also too
because diva is very much associated
with, with women.
- [Meena] Right.
It's one of those things- diva you think
of someone who's demanding and asking
for the best or what they
feel like they deserve.
- Yeah.
- And so diva is like, oh,
she's asking for too much.
When really it's like, somebody
probably treated that diva
like trash a lot of the time.
- (agreement)
- So she's like, yeah, I'm a diva.
I have to be this way.
Because you, you're trying me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I like that "D" and I like diva.
- Yeah.
- [Meena] Yeah.
- I gonna do-
- [Kelly] Do you-?
- Yeah, I have one.
I have "B," "B" black.
Just being black and what's, you know,
identity and I think a
lot of times growing up
people of color or a woman,
your identity is associated
with things that are both,
you know, bad and good
and it depends on where you
live and where you grew up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And how you internalize being black.
So "B" for black and
then probably like "T"
for trans and like trans lives matter
and protect trans people at all costs.
- Yeah.
- All of that, because it's like
identity and racial politics.
- [Meena] Yep.
- It's really important.
- Absolutely.
Do you have a word?
(applause)
You're like, he's like, I wanna go!
- Not as good as theirs. (laughs)
- [Meena] I know he has a word!
- He's like, I'm out! I'm out!
- I'll let them take this one. (laughs)
- I thought your word, Seth,
would be the letter "H."
- For "hi?"
(laughter)
- No, hot!
- I would never have thought "hi."
(laughter and applause)
- Oh my god.
Meena's new book is called
"A is for Ambitious".
Pick it up wherever you
get your books, everybody.
We always suggest a small bookstore.
All right? Shop locally.